alive and clearly exhausted
a young woman and a child are pulled
from the rubble
moments after the massive earthquake
homes and businesses lie flattened
the 7.2 magnitude quake struck at 8 30
in the morning sending people out into
the streets in panic
it was followed 20 minutes later by a
5.2 magnitude aftershock the tremors
felt across the caribbean and as far
away as southern florida
the epicenter is in the country's
western tip around 160 kilometers from
the densely populated capital
port-au-prince that bore the brunt of
the last major earthquake in 2010 that
left hundreds of thousands of people
dead
and one and a half million people
homeless
this latest quake is more powerful but
we don't yet know how deadly
that's larger than the 7.0 in 2010 that
killed over 200 000 people and while
that doesn't sound like a huge
difference in the size of the earthquake
that's about two times the energy
release
right now our impact estimates uh
are catastrophic i mean it's a
devastating earthquake
with potential of ten to hundreds of
thousands of people uh
fatalities
haiti is one of the poorest countries in
the world and plagued by worsening
instability and violence after the
assassination of the country's president
last month
haiti's also struggled to control a
surge in covert 19 cases in a country
where a quarter of the population live
in abject poverty
and now
this
leave parker al jazeera